hello and welcome to my shop today when
a customer come to fix his telephone I
put something very special on it an
amazing gift and we have hidden cameras
inside the store and outside on the
street so we see how they react but
first we wait for customer to come
hello okay hi there's something wrong
with my phone it keeps freezing let's
pull this phone this on the sound I take
a look at idea thank you all right okay
I'll be right there
okay my friend it was just a little
problem but it works fine it takes yeah
yeah also I put a special application
for you on this one
free of charge okay you look like a nice
guy because you're nice very beautiful
couple
oh thank you yeah no worries it's a
special gift from me to you
sounds cool you wanna see how it works
yes okay I show you okay you see the
light yeah okay now look oh my god like
off you can be romantic when you're
together yes any of your finish you put
light back on at least no yeah it works
nice yeah
love it man also it work outside really
yeah you want to see buddy I saw that's
a friggin here you see street light yeah
same principle again I heck doesn't made
you like that that's like the best time
ever
alright put it back on yeah do you like
car I I love cows yeah
okay here here we go it's not my car but
it's open
Oh like like sure it'd work with every
car come I'll show you before people see
us well so remember I will show you same
principle here we go
before people look at us okay you can do
more it work with atm look if I do this
by hand I tell you it's a special gift
okay I want you to type here you see the
traffic light okay I want you to try the
application when I count to three you
press the button one two three packet is
green so you can do it
I did you did that you see didn't do
that no no you oh no no I told you to
aim at that traffic like you aim at the
other one here don't run you have the
money put it away
it's gone don't worry a handle it ok
officer this car crash because this
woman what this man this man he do all
this problem all this problem what what
did you do he's trained he steal the
telephone from my store like oh he was
actually showing us he's a hacker he
hack into the system with what he use
his phone with this phone yeah Shema can
I see your phone
Shema your phone I I don't underst sum
up he hack into every system I tell you
he's gone speak English this one my
English your English not who serve the
phone sir what is this how'd he do that
sir he look ask him she gave it he gave
me the app would I give you nothing do
you honestly think a phone can do this
really I
you just experience what you can do in
the upcoming video game washdown Wow
watchdogs that's amazing that was
amazing really how it would be cool to
live in a world like that we call the
hack everything yeah what Oh